[Musik]
corona hotspot großstadt in vielen
deutschen metropolen drohen schärfere
regeln und eine ausgedehnte masten
pflicht umsturzpläne in michigan eine
gruppe von rechtsextremisten wollte
offenbar die gouverneurin entführen und
den us-bundesstaat ins chaos stürzen
besondere ehrung im kampf gegen hunger
das welternährungsprogramm der uno
erhält für seine arbeit den
friedensnobelpreis
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am freitag für
den sport ist norbert lehmann an meiner
seite kennengelernt so formiert alles
wird zurückkommen feiern ausgehen spaß
ohne krone regeln jetzt aber zählt etwas
anderes achtsamkeit und zusammenhalt die
botschaft der bundeskanzlerin heute
nachdem sie sich mit den oberhäuptern
der großen deutschen städte getroffen
hatte vor allem dort ist die situation
angespannt denn in immer mehr regionen
wird der kritische wert von 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner
überschritten
etwa in bremen berlin und frankfurt am
main
andere städte liegen nur knapp darunter
beispielsweise köln und essen
bundesweit meldete das robert koch
institut heute 4516 neuinfektionen im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
haben sich täglich 2009 110 menschen
angesteckt sylvia bleßmann berichtet
warten auf den corona test im berliner
stadtbezirk neukölln sind die zahlen der
mit 19 infizierten besonders dramatisch
gestiegen
viele versuchen mit einem negativ test
dem corona hotspot in den herbstferien
noch irgendwie zu entfliehen
angesichts solcher wachsenden
infektionszahlen drängte die kanzlerin
im gespräch darauf zusätzliche maßnahmen
einzuführen
es muss unser ziel sein die
infektionszahlen in einem bereich zu
halten wo möglichst jede einzelne
infektion nachverfolgt werden kann wo
kontaktpersonen erreicht und gewarnt
werden können und wo ist dann gelingt
infektionsketten auch wieder zu
durchbrechen ab 50 neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohner soll es umgehend neue
beschränkungen geben etwa masken pflicht
sperrstunden alkohol und kontaktverbot
mehr personal zum beispiel für
gesundheitsämter soll dann vom bund
kommen wir können ab fordern auch
experten des robert koch institutes und
der bundeswehr für die krisenstäbe im
zweifel würde auch die bundespolizei auf
anfrage helfen bei den kontrollen
auch medizinstudenten und abordnungen
aus verwaltungen sollen mithelfen
gesundheits und ordnungsämter bei
kontrollen zu entlasten
wir wollen auf jeden fall verhindern
dass es zu einem generellen shutdown in
deutschland kommt wir wollen auf jeden
fall verhindern dass kinder nicht mehr
die kitas in die schulen besuchen und
wir wollen möglichst alles dafür tun
dass wirtschaftliche entwicklung
ermöglicht werden die steigenden corona
zahlen zwingen kliniken bereits wieder
planbare eingriffe zu verschieben
die kommenden tage werden entscheiden
wie gut deutschland im winter da steht
schauen wir uns jetzt einen der
deutschen corona hotspots genauer am
frankfurt am main war im sommer noch ein
großer teil der neuansteckungen hier auf
reiserückkehrer zurückzuführen
gibt es jetzt wieder mehr lokale
ausbrüche und neuinfektion im alltag
über die lage in der metropole dominik
löschmeister seit heute gilt masten
pflicht auf vielen einkaufsstraßen in
frankfurt auf derzeit tragen die meisten
bereits eine aber nicht alle wissen von
den neuen regeln von der dame
angesprochen warum wir die maske nicht
in der hand also warum wir die nicht
tragen und draußen finde ich sinnlos
will ich ihnen ehrlich aber in den
gebäuden verstehe ich dass das hier
nochmals getragen ist ich persönlich
empfinde es richtig aktuell und hoffe
dass es bald wieder endet frankfurt
meldet 55 neuinfektionen pro 100000
einwohner innerhalb von sieben tagen ist
damit corona hotspot es gilt ein
alkoholverbot auf öffentlichen plätzen
eine sperrstunde ab 23 uhr für die
gastronomie alles nötig sagt das
gesundheitsamt
wir stellen jetzt eben fest dass
insbesondere durch die privaten feiern
und durch unsachgemäße besucher in den
gaststätten und und clubs dass es
dadurch jetzt eine ausbreitung in der
fläche gegeben hat im restaurant von
robert mangold häufen sich die absagen
die sperrstunde sei gift fürs geschäft
für ihn der falsche weg
sie hatten den sommer über zeit ein
reglement zu finden und halt auch durch
sanktionen dem wilden treiben den
hotspots einhalt zu gebieten das ist
monate nicht geschehen noch gebe es
genügend intensivbetten sagt die
frankfurter uniklinik ein problem aber
könnte der personalmangel werden
aussagen dass wir jetzt binnen 14 tagen
die gleiche anzahl an positiven
mitarbeitenden bei uns getestet haben
wie zuvor in drei monaten im frühjahr
und im sommer
frankfurt setzt darauf dass die bürger
die schärferen regeln mit tragen damit
die korona zahlen wieder runter gehen
eine besorgniserregende entwicklung die
weitere einschränkungen mit sich bringt
aber wie kommt das bei der bevölkerung
an
eine frage die uns das politbarometer
beantworten kann mitgebracht von
matthias fornoff hallo matthias hallo
pizza genannt was halten denn nun die
menschen beispielsweise von der inhalt
deutschen quarantäne pflicht was man
sieht den zahlen schon an dass die
meisten deutschen die steigende
gefährdung wahrnehmen und auch gut
finden wenn gegengesteuert wird
wer aus einem inländischen risikogebiet
kommt soll in quarantäne gehen das
finden 64 prozent
ein knappes drittel ist dagegen die
anhänger aller parteien sind
mehrheitlich für eine quarantäne
bei der ard sind die meinungen geteilt
die geltenden corona maßnahmen sind
richtig sagen knapp zwei drittel
und fast jeder vierte findet sie müssten
sogar noch härter ausfallen wenn die
infektionszahlen weiter steigen dann
rechnen 77 prozent damit das ist wieder
stärkere einschränkungen geben wird 21
prozent erwarten das nicht da wäre dann
die frage ob beziehungsweise wie sich
das handeln der regierung auf ihre
beliebtheit und die der opposition
auswirkt wie würde dann gewählt wenn
jetzt wahlen wären
na das kräfteverhältnis der parteien das
ist zurzeit ziemlich stabil
wenn am nächsten sonntag bundestagswahl
wäre käme die union auf 37 prozent spd
16 1 af d10 fdp 5 linke 7 grüne 20 + 1
das würde dann reichen für schwarz grün
und schwarz rot nicht aber für grün-rot
brot zu einem ganz anderen thema nach
den antisemitischen angriffen der
letzten zeit
haben wir gefragt wie groß ist die
judenfeindlichkeit in deutschland sehr
groß sagen 3% groß 31 prozent nicht so
groß 52 prozent und nur 7 prozent
glauben dass es gar keine
judenfeindlichkeit bei uns gibt
herzlichen dank matthias mehr vom
politbarometer gibt es in der zdf-
heute- app oder ab 22 uhr auch im heute
journal
verfassungsschutzpräsident haldenwang
blickt mit sorge auf den antisemitismus
im land straftaten gegen juden und
jüdische einrichtungen in deutschland
hätten erheblich zugenommen
ein beispiel der anschlag von halle vor
genau einem jahr am höchsten jüdischen
feiertag jom kippur hatte der täter
versucht in der synagoge der stadt ein
massaker auszurichten
als ihm das nicht gelang schoss er zwei
menschen in der nähe
die stadt hat mit verschiedenen
veranstaltungen heute der opfer gedacht
annette busch
sie ist zum symbol geworden dafür wie
gefährdet das jüdische leben in
deutschland ist die tür die den schüssen
stand hielt als vor einem jahr ein
rechtsextremist versucht hatte in diesem
lager einzudringen
bevor er dann in der nähe zwei menschen
erschoss aus der tür ist ein denkmal
geworden die 19 jährige lydia edel hat
es geschaffen sie selbst ist christlich
orthodox es soll quasi den anstoß geben
beziehungsweise vermitteln dass man
diesem tag auf gar keinen fall vergessen
sollte trotzdem soll auch dieses denkmal
vermitteln dass das leben weitergeht
seit dem anschlag steht an der synagoge
immer ein polizeiwagen dass das nötig
ist erfülle ihn mit scham und zorn so
bundespräsident steinmeier bei der
zentralen gedenkveranstaltung in der
ulrichskirche ein jahr ist vergangen
aber der schmerz sind setzen es nicht
gewichen
meine gedanken und mein tiefes mitgefühl
gelten heute den menschen die ihre
liebsten liebsten verloren haben als
bundespräsident möchte ich ihnen den
angehörigen heute sagen wir stehen an
ihrer seite
wir alle die menschen in unserem land
trauern mit ihnen kaum zu wort kamen
hier angehörige der getöteten und
überlebende des attentats ganz anders in
dieser ausstellung von hallenser
studenten und aktivisten mit langen
interviews geben sie den betroffenen
eine stimme damit sie stärker
wahrgenommen werden
denn ihr gedenken findet nicht nur heute
statt ihr schmerz und ihre erinnerungen
dauern ein leben lang
andreas weise ist für uns in halle
andreas w geht alle mit diesem ersten
gedenkt tag ein jahr nach dem anschlag
um
man spürt hier schon in halle dass da
eine große solidarität da ist mit den
opfern mit den angehörigen der opfer
heute mittag um kurz nach zwölf genau
dem zeitpunkt als vor einem jahr der
anschlag auf die synagoge losging da
stand hier auf dem marktplatz hinter mir
in halle und an vielen anderen orten das
öffentliche leben für einige minuten
still in trauernden gedenken
und wenn man mit dem gemeindevorsteher
der synagoge max private key spricht
dann sagt er was ihn hier sehr
beeindruckt hat in den letzten jahr
das war vor allem die solidarität der
menschen aus halle er hat immer gesagt
das sind keine politiker die müssen
nicht kommen das sind menschen die
wolken kommen wollten zeigen dass sie
sozusagen an der seite der jüdischen
gemeinde stehen und in halle dieses
gedenken und diese solidarität ist
wirklich groß allerdings auch immer noch
die bestürzt über die tat vor genau
einem jahr
vielen dank andreas schauen wir in die
usa
das angespannte politische klima vor der
präsidentenwahl wird weiter aufgeheizt
die demokratische gouverneur in von
michigan grätschen widmer sollte
offenbar von einer rechtsextremen miliz
entführt werden
das fbi nahmen 13 extremisten fest
widmer gilt als scharfe kritikerin von
donald trump sie war auf den präsidenten
wieder vor sich nicht klar von weißen
rassisten zu distanzieren
britta jäger ermittler durchsuchten
wohnungen der verdächtigen an
verschiedenen orten im bundesstaat
michigan
sie stellen unter anderem gewehre und
pistolen sicher es gibt insgesamt 13
festnahmen
das fbi hatte seine untersuchungen schon
früher im jahr begonnen als es über die
sozialen medien erfahren hatte dass eine
gruppe über gewalt gegen teile der
regierung und verschiedene beamte in
michigan diskutiert hatte die
mutmaßlichen extremisten haben die
demokratische gouverneur in von michigan
grätschen widmen führen und einen
bürgerkrieg anzetteln wollen
scharfe kritik von widmer am us
präsidenten der sich im tv-duell
vergangene woche wiederholt weigerte
rechte gruppen eindeutig zu verurteilen
truppen haben die worte des präsidenten
nicht als zurechtweisen und sondern als
mobilisierung verstanden als einen ruf
zu handeln wenn sich politische führer
mit inländischen terroristen treffen sie
unterstützen sicher brüdern legitimieren
sie deren aktionen widmer wurde wegen
ihrer strengen chor ohne restriktionen
in michigan zum feindbild vor allem
radikaler tromp anhänger ende april
zogen die bewaffnet ins
parlamentsgebäude
diese und ähnliche aktionen befeuerte
jump mit aufrufen zur befreiung
demokratisch geführte städte auch auf
die jüngsten verhaftungen reagiert er
statt ihn zu kritisieren sollte widme
sich lieber bedanken dass
sicherheitskräfte der regierung ihrer
entführung verhindert hätten
kurz vor der präsidentschaftswahl trump
nichts um die aufgeheizte stimmung zu
dämpfen
seit zwei wochen gibt es in der
kaukasusregion berg karabach neue
blutige kämpfe
heute nun ein vermittlungsversuch und
zwar in moskau wo sich die
aussenminister der konfliktparteien
aserbaidschan und armenien zu gesprächen
trafen in berg karabach wird unterdessen
weiter gekämpft
mehrere hundert menschen sind bereits
ums leben gekommen die überwiegend von
christlichen armeniern bewohnte region
gehört völkerrechtlich zum islamisch
geprägten aserbaidschan seit 1994 gilt
eigentlich eine waffenruhe
plötzlich ist wieder unklar wer das neue
sturmgewehr der bundeswehr liefern soll
denn das verteidigungsministerium zieht
den zuschlag an den hersteller hänel
überraschend zurück grund ist eine
mögliche patentrechtsverletzung die
thüringer hatten sich unerwartet gegen
das angebot von heckler & koch
durchgesetzt
der bisherige lieferant hatte daraufhin
geklagt es geht um 120.000 gewehre für
250 millionen euro
berlin friedrichshain liebig straße 34
eine der letzten adressen mit hohem
symbolwert für die hausbesetzer szene
der hauptstadt schon in den 90er jahren
wurde das heruntergekommene anwesen
besetzt und seither als links altern
dieses wohnprojekt genutzt jetzt kam der
gerichtsvollzieher mit dem
räumungsbeschluss flankiert von einem
großaufgebot der polizei romanesco war
kurz nach sieben beginnt die räumung die
polizei wird ein fenster zum einstieg
begleitet von protesten und weiträumig
abgesperrt werden personen einzeln aus
dem haus heraus geführt die meisten
leisten keinen widerstand
wir haben da drin natürlich diverse
hindernisse aufgefunden wir uns daran
gehindert haben weiter in dem objekt vor
anzuschalten alle etagen zu erschließen
das war anspruchsvoll der kräfte sie
haben das ja aber wenn man auf die uhr
gucken ging es dann doch vergleichsweise
schnell die liebigstraße 34 und ein
benachbartes haus letzte überbleibsel
einer einst großen hausbesetzerszene
westberlin anfang der 80er jahre über
100 häuser werden damals besetzt als
zeichen gegen abriss und leer statt
nach der wende schwappt das phänomen in
den ostteil der stadt
heute gilt die gegend um das geräumte
haushalts kriminalitäts belasteter ort
anlaufstelle militante linksextremisten
sagt beschädigungen einschüchterungen im
kiez werden immer wieder kritisiert
forscher sehen deutliche unterschiede zu
früher
sie hatten auch unterstützung wie so
schön heißt aus bürgerlichen kreisen
torwart universitätsprofessoren da die
da auch mal genächtigt haben und so
weiter
und diese unterstützung ist eigentlich
doch heute relativ schwach geworden die
form des barrikaden protestes scheint
größere gruppen nicht mehr zu erreichen
obwohl wohnungsmangel und mieterhöhung
noch dringendere themen sind als früher
in deutschland werden immer mehr neue
autos mit elektro oder hybridantrieb
verkauft ihr marktanteil bei den
neuzulassungen lag im september bei 15,6
prozent vor einem jahr waren es noch
weniger als vier prozent um den ausbau
privater ladestationen zu fördern hat
nun der bundesrat das
wohnungseigentumsgesetz geändert so
haben nun auch mieter das recht auf
eigene kosten eine ladevorrichtung zu
installieren
es ist ein stolzer moment für das
welternährungsprogramm
die organisation erhält in diesem jahr
die wichtigste politische auszeichnung
den friedensnobelpreis seit 1961 kämpft
das world food programm gegen den hunger
oft an vorderster front in den ärmsten
und den gefährlichsten regionen der welt
so konnten im vergangenen jahr fast 100
millionen menschen in 88 ländern
versorgt und das heißt gerettet werden
david sauer berichtet sie kämpfen gegen
den hunger und für den frieden bringen
reis bohnen mail auch dorthin wo sonst
niemand hilft der friedensnobelpreis
eine anerkennung für die helferinnen und
helfer in aller welt darunter viele
freiwillige unsere leute sind an den
schwierigsten orten der welt dort wo es
krieg gibt klima extreme und trotzdem
sind sie da und haben diese auszeichnung
verdient
menschen die oft übersehen werden
doch in oslo heute auf die große bühne
gehoben werden ihre arbeit bekämpft
nicht nur hunger sondern gibt auch
hoffnung auf stabilität und frieden
die un organisation mit sitz in rom
finanziert sich überwiegend aus
freiwilligen zuwendungen die korona
pandemie hat vor allem in den
krisenregionen die versorgung mit
lebensmitteln erschwert als linienflüge
kaum noch möglich waren startete das
welternährungsprogramm flugzeuge risiko
ist dabei steter begleiter die
mitarbeiter begeben sich oft selber in
gefahr für andere
wir haben mehr als 100 leute verloren in
den 50 jahren des world food programm
das das ist auch ein preis für sie
gefährlich war es auch im märz 2009 10
als in mosambik zu klon idee wütete er
zerstörte straßen und brücken und
hunderttausende hektar nutzpflanzen die
organisation half dort mit als erstes
und ist noch immer vor ort
seit fast 60 jahren hilft das
welternährungsprogramm zu land zu wasser
aus der luft einfach überall
hunger gelitten und hilfe gebraucht wird
tja und nun zu dir norbert und zum
nations league spiel deutschland gegen
die ukraine morgen abend ja und er
lautet die devise von bundestrainer
joachim löw erstens abschotten
die ukraine ist ja corona gebiet und
zweitens gewinnen das wäre eine premiere
in diesem jahr schließlich drittens
hochmotiviert heimfliegen zum nächsten
spiel gegen die schweiz am dienstag mit
23 spielern sind sie angereist alle
haben am abend in der arena mit
trainiert und sind einsatzbereit auch
die zuletzt angeschlagenen groß und
werner wegen der infektions lage wird
sich das team nur modell und stadion
aufhalten
in deutschland steigen die zahlen hier
aus ständiger sie denke die vorsicht ist
überall für jeden einzelnen geboten und
jeder hält sich an diese maßnahmen die
vorgegeben sind strikt löw kann wieder
auf den kompletten bayern-block um
kapitän neuer setzen
trotz der angespannten pandemie lage
sind 20.000 fans zugelassen das motto
des bundestrainers gewinnen und gesund
bleiben erstes männer halbfinale der
french open rafael nadal gegen den
argentinier diego sebastian schwarz man
am ende ein klarer dreisatz erfolg des
titelverteidigers aus spanien nadals 99
sieg im 100 erste spiel in paris
er ist der ungekrönte könig der french
open rafael nadal
der wohl beste sandplatzspieler aller
zeiten sein gegner diego schwarzmann ist
in seinem ersten grand slam halbfinale
chancenlos nadal diktiert von beginn an
das geschehen mit seinen extremen
topspin schlägen und stellt die weichen
schon früh auf sie mit jeweils 6 zu 3
gegen die sätze eins und zwei an den
china der sich dann auch im tie break
des dritten satzes klar überlegen zeigt
und weiter ohne satzverlust
auf seinen dann schon 13 titel in paris
zusteuert könnte ein richtiges
traumfinale werden nadal gegen den
weltranglisten ersten novak djokovic
der muss aber heute abend noch sein
zweites sein halbfinale gegen die
griechen gewinnen
warten wir es ab ok herbstlich kühl mit
regen aber auch sonnenschein so
präsentiert sich der samstag mehr zum
wetter gleich von katja horneffer das
war es von uns danke für ihr interesse
marietta slomka meldet sich gegen 10 mit
dem heute journal
wir wünschen einen entspannten
freitagabend und sagen tschüss bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren ii
fester dreht sich hier gerade über der
nordsee und das bringt regenschauer und
gewitter von der nordseeküste zu uns
herein
wir haben es aber auch noch mit den
resten eines tief namens doris zu tun
und so schüttelt es heute nacht am
kräftigsten hier zwischen der ruder- und
dem oberrhein
im nordwesten gibt es regenschauer und
gewitter und dazwischen bildet sich aber
auch mal nebel
die temperaturen sinken auf werte
zwischen 12 grad in der lausitz und 6
grad an der mosel und steigen morgen am
alpenrand nur auf neun grad da wird es
dann am mildesten am oberrhein mit 15
grad
regenschauer und gewitter der nacht
ziehen im laufe des tages weiter nach
süden erreichen also auch den
niederrhein und später dann auch die
ostsee zwischen dem mecklenburger
seenplatte und dem harz und dann auch
zwischen dem thüringer wald und im
oberrhein zeigt sich aber morgen doch
häufig die sonne
denn diese regenwolken ziehen sich immer
mehr richtung südosten zurück
am sonntag ändert sich beim wetter wenig
ist wird allerdings ein bisschen kühler
mit höchsttemperaturen von nur noch 6
bis 13 grad und auch die neue woche
startet windig wechselhaft und kühl
schönes wochenende